Ngoài Mui Bệnh Thằng Sáo, chỉ cuộc thủ vực một cho biết trong giai đạn đầu trị khai nghị định số
bệnh 15,529,540 vụ về hoa đơn định từ hợi tạo từ máy tính tiền.
Cơ quan thươi chưa đặt ra việc sự phát, mà tập trung tuên chuyển khổ chở hộ kinh dành làm quen chính sách mới.
Chính sách này không làm thay đổi giữ vụ thủy, không gây sảo chuẩn thoại đầu kinh dành.
Tinh định ngày 15,560,529, tại Hanoi có 480,570 hộ kinh dành thuộc dịn mắt bộ đã đăng ký sự dụng hoa đơn định từ.
Cộng mỗi nghĩ nắm trong 15 mốt hộ tưởng viện áp dụ, năng tổ sổ hộ sử dụng lên gần chính nghiệm hộ đã 1 chăm tắm với vình chăm chỉ tiêu.
Chứ không tin cho rằng một số chữa lớn như động sôn, ninh hiệp, là phù có hệ tưởng nghị bản vì chính sách mới, chỉ cuộc thử hàng định không có biến đậu lớn.
Nghe nhận chỉ có hai chăm sóm với ba hộ mừng kinh dân sò phải dùng hoa đơn địa từ chiếm tám phải tám vình chăm trên tổng số hộ mừng,
nghĩ kinh dân và chiếm năm vình chăm số hộ thuộc dịch áp dụng hoa đơn địa từ hợi tạo từ máy tính tiền.
Điều dùng hoa đơn địa từ giúp mình bạch xanh thu, không bằng giữa vụ thế và hưởng tới môi trường kinh dân hiện đại, mình bứng.
Cơ quan thử tiếp tục đồng hành cùng hộ kinh dân trong quá trình chuyển đổi số, không chỉ thủ thủy khoản quá khu nếu dân thu và sinh tăng só sử dụng hoa đơn.